there's so much you can do to a novel
that uh that can't be done on screen
what's more difficult writing a novel or
writing a screenplay oh good question
they're
they're both very dif for me for so for
me i always write i write out scenes so
i don't write i don't go straight to the
screenplay
i can write the whole scene
and then i can i then i convert it to
the screenplay
so i'm kind of always adapting
prose to a script which is probably the
worst way to write a script but it's
kind of the way i approach it
so for me the novel is always
the novel is always most important to me
if someone said you you you gotta you
gotta make a choice right now are you
writing novels for the rest of your life
are you writing screenplays for the rest
of your life i immediately novels that's
it i'm good
um but i love film and i love the art of
screenwriting
um
and
i they both have their challenges the
the beauty and the and they're both
beautiful in their own ways the beauty
the beauty of the novel is
if you screw up a novel you screwed up
the novel and your name is on that
if you may if it's a great novel
it's a great novel and your name is on
that so when you're the screenwriter
if the movie doesn't do that well
there's hundreds of people that could
have
you know been part of the problem the
movie does great there's hundreds of
people that could have been part of the
greatness
uh so
there it's it's once a team sport and
one's a solo sport
i
can
in both of them
in screenwriting it's a solo sport when
you're writing your script
so i thrive in that and then
but i also thrive in
problem solving i want them to go
through and give me notes and go you
know scene 23 cut that out scene 42 we
need this and i'm like great and i need
to know my screenplay back and forth so
i'll be like
scene 23 we cut that out that means that
we're going to lose scene 18 and this in
the breadcrumb from scene three
and so
it's
that i love getting in the technical
part of that and i i guess i do it with
both
um i don't
i don't find um
i don't you know they're both separate
but they're both so the same because
we're both
they're both putting it on the page
if that makes sense so with
screenwriting it's like a game of jenga
so if you're pulling something from the
bottom
that that's not going to make sense and
and the whole thing could topple
unless it's properly weighted it's got
to be it's got to be
constructed properly or else yeah the
whole thing's gonna fall down yeah same
with the novel i mean you could totally
screw up a novel by
you know
going going too much or too little
there's the the technicals of it are
similar it's uh
they just both have to be crafted
um
and
the the beauty the beauty of cinema is i
mean
and we i think i see it a lot you see
bad screenplays that are good films
because the directors and the actors
come in
and if you just really sat there and
read the screenplay and then you watch
what the actors and the directors
brought to it and you go
wow
what a crap screenplay but what a
beautiful film
and
there's there's a lot of bad
screenwriters out there that
make great movies you know it's uh
it's such an interesting game yeah
what about prose writing and thought
process versus screenwriting and thought
process in terms of showing the
characters going through something in
their mind
that yeah that's when so when we're when
we're on the screenplay that's when
that's when we have to
show uh we we show a lot less
there's a lot more breathing room so
uh
the the novel where we're bringing we're
bringing the reader through the novel
and through all the internal process
thought processes in the screenplay
we're
taking the characters there
but
we also have to let the director do
their job and the actors do their job
and we just kind of have to and just
give a little bit of intention a little
bit of note this happens this happens
they don't need to in the novel it could
be oh why this happened it could go
around this way
but it's it's um get the essence of it
you just really put the emotional
essence in there
and not too much emotional essence
because let the let everyone
um
let everyone do their job and they're
gonna and the and the
the
great directors do great work and
they're great actors do great work and
if you do put too much in there you
could be
impeding what they need to do on uh on
their end as as part of their job
do novels and screenplays have the same
structure
uh
screenplays are
i don't know because
you can really screw around with a novel
structure you can't screw around with
the screenwriting structure and anyone
who's like
um oh wow this is experimental and you
look at it and there and you go that's
still three acts and i can tell you
exactly where those act breaks are
because it's hard to break that
pattern we know we've been told these
stories through film
for over a century a certain way
and if you know if the first act goes 45
minutes
the audience may not understand the
first act is going 45 minutes but
they'll understand that
there's something wrong with the film
and i think i could just go to the
bathroom and get up some popcorn right
now
and they won't know why
so we are really structured
to have
uh the
the hero on the singular journey for the
most part and the act breaks and the
escalating attention as it is with you
know with the novel you can
uh daniel evsky's house of leaves just
that that book right there just you know
that turns the novel on its side but
it's a novel uh we can really
there's so much you can do to a novel
that uh that can't be done on screen
as there's so much you do on screen that
can't be done to a novel i mean you can
there's you know you you don't describe
an actor
i mean you don't in the you don't
describe a character feeling sad and why
they feel sad
all you got to do is see a look all you
need is a reaction on an actor's face
and that will tell you what five pages
of the novel can tell you
so that's when it's beautiful
on the screen and then
when it's beautiful in the book too
yeah i've been looking at walter tevis's
uh
so the hustler and then um the queen's
gambit and then
um you know it's been a while since i've
actually seen the hustler but then
seeing queen's gambit and just just the
differences just kind of like there a
lot of it was very close to the novel
maybe it was cleaned up there were parts
that were cleaned up more um maybe for
certain audiences um with the queen's
gambit for for the series it wasn't in
some there were some details that were
maybe too
uh you know sexually explicit or
whatever um but um you know so just did
she still see the uh chess on the roof
she did yeah i think so but it wasn't
totally i mean it was it was the because
that was where she took these these
pills that she you know went into this
world and that's how she kind of
disassociated and was able to take
herself out of the world of the
orphanage in bad situations and she
would see that as a way to
um not be in her reality yeah and so um
there was that but yeah it's interesting
to compare
and and
you know oftentimes usually the book it
seems like is is more enjoyable
sometimes but then when you see these
characters come to life and you like the
actors yeah it's a whole another
experience yeah
so anyway i'm not sure where i was going
with that but
i'm not sure where i'm going with
anything so i'm glad we're on the same
page that's all right
and we're just having fun here okay so